this is macro
successful type stuff like how to be
successful in your career so i saw this
article from cnbc i said i got to share
with my people so here's what it is it's
called the six stages
of career growth i'm sure david's
pulling it up right now what's up so the
six stages of career growth so look no
matter what field you're in
it doesn't matter what your job is what
your career is where you're at in life
you're gonna go through these six stages
so we're gonna break these things right
down
and there's a master plan
for your career path so here are the six
stages and i'll break them down one by
one by one the six stages of a career
path are number one a follower that's
how you start off as a follower then you
become a collaborator then you become an
instructor then you become a manager
then you become the all-holy influencer
and last but not least you become
the leader so let's get into these six
things let's see where you're at
on this totem pole of career right so
here are the six stages so number one
you start off as a follower now this is
ev we've all been here this is for the
day one newbies out there whether you
just got out of college whether you're
an internship whether this is your first
job
we've all been there it's not it's fun
it's exciting but you're a low man or
woman on the totem pole
um but you gotta start somewhere this is
like rookie year right
um
you're doing tasks you're paying your
dues
you're basically doing what you're told
and if you do that well maybe you'll
move on to the next level you know uh
my friend marcelo once said you know
unless your mom is beyonce you're not
born an influencer okay like you got to
pay your dues you got to get somewhere
you got to start at point a like i
remember when david came
valuetainment
oh rookie year
that was the he showed up he had long
hair he was frazzled maybe a little
speck of a mustache just growing
fresh hair
strong mustache
you're in the instructor manager phase i
would like to say okay okay but you know
you started off as a follower so that's
step one yeah okay we've all been there
right my first job i was just green as
can be i started off doing radio sales
that was my first job after college i
was working for clear channel clear
channel radio which is now i heart media
i was just getting in where i fit in i
had a good manager i followed my his
lead i listened i learned i uh i
collaborated with the team and improved
and that leads me to number two what's
number two on this list being
a collaborator
because they say that the teamwork
makes the dream work so
when you're into the second phase of a
career path you're a collaborator now
what does that mean you're working
closely with others right you're
developing valuable people skills by
collaborating with your team so there's
a book that we read here at
valuetainment called the ideal team
player how much of an ideal team player
are you right were you here when we read
that i think no it was before my time
okay before your time but basically um
being an ideal team player
there's certain qualities that you need
to have i think it was being smart
um being effective certain qualities but
the point is is that you're a good
team player because i got bad news for
you if you don't play well with others
you're not gonna make it well i've all
got that person in in the office or the
person that you work with or the person
in your organization you're like this
guy's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know and that person's not gonna
last long hopefully that person's not
your boss
but if you're all if they're you know
we've all done group projects yeah right
collaborating we all work with with
different people people different skill
sets
you know
when someone's yo this person's awesome
they're great to work with word will
travel about that person much like you
young david word traveled very quickly
young david's doing his thing
however
there's other people that word travels
very fast that they're not exactly fun
to collaborate with right maybe they're
doing
some not nice things we can name some
names but we won't there's some people
that are going to come to mind david but
if you don't play well with others and
you don't work with others you're not
going to make it to the next level
you're going to go from job to job to
job to jobs being a follower being a
rookie starting over not collaborating
well and you just stay at level one stay
at level two and you always want to
blame someone else well my manager was
an [ __ ] my boss did this he didn't
let me do it it's always somebody else
it's the person that doesn't succeed at
number two
being a good collaborator that's always
going to place blame and it's so easy to
place blame on others yeah it's so hard
to look in the mirror amen so hard yeah
again if you don't play well with others
you're not gonna make it so once you
learn you start off as a follower you
pay your dues you become a collaborator
a team player
all of a sudden people recognize hey
this this person's got some leadership
skills we're not gonna make them the
boss yet but we're gonna we're gonna
bump him up we're gonna say all right
this person is now gonna become
an instructor an instructor
is like
it's like time to step up and take the
lead
but not too much you're not getting the
whole lead a little bit a little bit of
a lead right yeah this is basically has
junior manager vibes all over it yeah
there's actually a point mario made uh
in his uh intrapreneur series number
point number one was uh yeah don't trust
too early it's like yeah we like you but
little by little we'll kind of give you
more of that leash yeah
you got to have a leash right so give my
someone a leash sometimes uh totally run
and have a great time or sometimes you
give them enough rope to hang themselves
you heard that before
so you know when you're the instructor
you're calling the shots on projects
you're leading a few people under you
some people are answering to you you're
not the manager you're like the
assistant to the
to the regional man you're basically
like dwight schrute
you're the assistant to
the regional manager
right you're not michael scott yet yeah
you're dwight schrute okay but as a
junior manager we all know that you know
that's obviously a an office reference
um
but
again
rookie year you're starting off as a
follower you collaborate well with
playing without others you level up now
you're an instructor
you're teaching others and then
eventually
eventually you will get to
manager and doesn't necessarily need to
be
the role of manager
but it's basically when people
answer to you it's when people are
saying all right this person's got it
going on in this case it might be
michael scott from the office you just
graduated from
dwight schrute to michael scott wow this
is obviously a
an office reference yeah there's a lot
of calamity that we can you know bring
up with all this but basically what that
happens when you become the manager that
means the company trusts you they said
this person
they got it going on right
uh they can trust you to lead the team
they can trust you to spearhead
important tasks uh implement big plans
basically gsd get [ __ ] done yeah so
um
who comes to mind that's a good
manager right like a this is almost like
a team leader yeah not the company
leader but team you know you know this
is a very obscure reference oh boy but
i'm a big basketball fan miami heat fan
nba season just started we're gonna be
touching on that but there's a player on
the miami heat who's my age 40 years old
eudonis haslam
he's been on the team forever yeah i
played against him in high school no you
did not yeah i swear did you really yeah
you're doing something
okay miami high baby yeah um but he he
doesn't even play anymore he plays like
i think he played like one game yeah he
just kind of makes two million bucks a
year greatest seat in the whole place
best seat in the house uh i think he
played one game last year scored like
four points two rebounds and got a fight
with dwight howard when he got that
kicked out of the game anyway but he's a
team leader they want him on the team
because he sets the tone baby yeah he
sets the tone so that's what it is it's
almost like a manager michael scott
udonis haslam
the team your teammates trust you okay
so that's manager again start off as a
follower collaborator instructor manager
then here's where things get interesting
number five
is an influencer and an influencer
indeed this is where things get
interesting and the world
starts to take notice of you right so
you know the the term influencer gets a
bad rep right oh he's an influencer oh
as an influencer but the reality is is
that you're starting to influence
people's minds and influence the culture
okay
um
you might influence people within your
organization you might influence people
locally nationally or even globally
right so who are some all-star
influencers that come to mind like
all-star all-star in florida like the
rock yeah the major influencer the
kardashians the jake uh the paul
brothers right um even like little ryan
from ryan's world these are you know
influencers totally uh but then you have
a little like you have micro influencers
like someone that's only got 5 000 or 10
000 or 20 000 followers but they're the
best
at a very specific thing and people
follow them would you consider yourself
an influencer yeah i mean in the
financial world 100 percent okay
yourself an influencer yeah all right
i'll take it there you go i'll take it
but um yeah i think that's where i'm at
in my career right now because i've done
i started rookie year i did that i
played well with others i collaborated i
became an instructor i had a team that
was under me eventually i i grew up i
was leading the team i was leading us i
became vp of sales at my financial firm
running the show and then when i made
some loot and i said all right let me
branch out from just my company
to
you know
the the the scene if you will
yeah i think i became an influencer at
that point where i'm not at
i don't think
is that step six yet i think that's
still what i need to accomplish and the
final stage
is becoming a leader
right so like even if we look at our
organization here at valuetainment i
would say pbd is the leader a hundred
percent
by far
and foremost then you've got you know
influencers myself gerard phil heath to
a higher extent yeah right
um toms that whatever you want to put
like and then there's you know managers
mario right eric all right then you got
instructors right you
uh you know certain rob you know whoever
and then we got team members then you've
got you know rookies they've just been
here for like a month yeah maris lacey's
all right
shout out you said that that's exactly
what i did
so but when you enter the leadership
stage of your career
uh the most important thing that you're
doing is doing things bigger
than yourself your whole goal and your
whole mindset is to empower
others
right
it's not just about yourself it's about
empire empowering and inspiring
others right it's showing people what to
do how to think uh how to react
something bigger than yourself right so
you know in the business world who comes
to mind you know major leaders right uh
elon musk
right jeff bezos even steve jobs always
pbd in the house
in the sports world major leaders right
cristiano ronaldo ronaldo right now of
course you're gonna go lebron tom brady
these are leaders adam sosnick that's
right that's right so
what's my point in all this the most
important thing you can do in all this
is now that you have this blueprint now
that you understand that there's you
know a
a there's levels to this game right
there's levels like shout out to avicii
there's levels to this
where are you
in the totem pole of your career are you
just starting out
right are you are you already at the
influencer phase are you working well
with others are you not working well
with others which one is it so
step one if i'm watching this and you
know there's people watching this right
now if i'm you i say all right dude i
just got started cool now i know what
step two is or hey man i've been working
on my this job for two years now i'm
still in the collaborator phase how can
i level up
to become
a manager right or an instructor like
what's the next level so or if you're
stuck at that influencer phase like me
life's good you're making money you've
got some clout you're an influencer
are you a leader
are you a leader because when you become
a leader that's when things change well
yeah it's in
i mean just a note on that is something
that pbd says it's like not everyone is
meant to be number one like some guys
are meant to be number two some guys are
like great at being number threes yes so
it's like
you know if if you find yourself maybe
stuck at influencer maybe you're not
stuck maybe that's just the best you're
you're at and that's not a bad thing
yeah i think your people are meant to be
i 100 percent agree with what pbs says
on that it's like not everyone's meant
to be the number one dude 100 not
everybody can be the number one
organization especially if you've got a
hundred or a thousand or ten thousand
people in the organization that means be
the best number three the be the best
you're the like look at we'll use the
udonis has them as an example
homie doesn't even play anymore but he's
he's the captain of the team he's a
leader know your role right he's like
look i'm number 15. straight up but i'm
the best 15 in the freaking league yeah
exactly right
so the most important thing is
understand that the you know you don't
have to just like take the resurrect
like
right there's levels to this game
there's a blueprint for this game
there's only six steps so if you're at
one you're only five away if you're at
three you're only three away you're at
five one more baby and you're a leader
so
uh i really like that that um
this topic this was something that i
when i saw i said
uh this is something we have to address
so just to recap
find out where you're at in this totem
pole right now of um
of your career path again you start off
as a follower become a collaborator you
play well with others you get an upgrade
to being an instructor right junior
manager vibes uh vibe shout out to
dwight schrute then you become the
manager like michael scott then you
become an influencer and then you become
the lead we talk is money
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
size cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken